Is important because our future depends on it.
Today we ask our volunteers
why they think that voting for the next European election
is important. I believe in democracy,
and I believe that people should decide for their future.
I think the voting is very important
because if you don't tell your opinion,
you will be managed by the people that you don't like.
It is important because with this vote,
we can change the future of the Rasmus plus program.
Important to make your country better and also the whole world better.
So vote, guys,
because if we. If we don't,
we don't have need to have democracy whatsoever.
I believe it's important to vote
at the next European Parliament elections
because we can shape the future of Europe and, uh,
of the Erasmus program.
On the 7th and 9th of June, please vote.